I saw this last night I had I had a
blast okay
it is you guys you're like I eat no no
not at all I had like I had a lot of fun
watching this thing and you guys have
made it that I will never return a purse
okay that I ever find I've never helped
anyone across the street I'm not gonna
open doors for people right oh no it's a
being serious for a second the thing I
also really enjoyed about it is that it
flips the normal trope on its head it's
all women in this movie letting you know
um I'm assuming this is one of the
reasons you got drawn to the project
well I think you know for me when I
first read the project and and saw that
it was you know three women women at the
helm it reminded me of get out in the
sense that it subverts the genre it's a
story that's attainable that we
understand but being that it's a
separate lens and it's a different cast
it subverts the genre in a way that
makes it more exciting more innovative
and something that feels more modern and
you know the Anthony Hopkins characters
Isabella pair and the boyfriend
characters and said my best friend and
those are things that I felt were an
interesting modern twist on an exciting
you know pulpy fun thriller I really
enjoyed seeing misses cinematography
yeah talked a little bit about working
with him because it's cool that like the
beginning it's shot like a completely
different movie and then it just flips
completely yeah you know I think that
working with Seamus McGarvey he is in my
opinion I'm obsessed with
cinematographers every movie I do I
always the first question I have when I
talk to doctor I'm like who's your
cinematographer what's your idea because
I think it's probably I think besides
the editor I think it's the largest part
of the film much larger than that and
even the actors and for me I was always
a massive fan of Seamus but the way that
Neil and Seamus is relationship really
panned out on screen was really special
Neil has a very heavy hand and in the
the fantasy world he likes to create you
know look at in dreams or interview of
the vampire he creates these kind of
twisted fairy tales and that really
happened in this film I warned it to he
really wanted to be that you know when
you sit down you watch the film if you
haven't seen the trailer
he wanted you to believe that it was
gonna be a love story that it was going
to be this beautiful kind of
star-crossed friendship you know that's
coming together in the darkest of times
and then you wanted that sucker punch to
really land when it becomes the dark
twisted fairy tale that it does and I
think it was really perfectly executed
I'm curious you've worked with some very
very talented directors how much have
you been paying attention on set and
like sort of mentally taking notes for
the day that maybe you want to like make
a movie is directing something you're
even remotely interested in oh very much
so yeah I you know I was even from a
young age from 5 years old six years old
I was always obsessed with what
everything else
what have everyone else was doing on set
than me I want to know why the prop
master was doing that when they set
designer was doing that you know I was
obsessed with color palettes as a kid
that was a massive deal for me and and
then of course the natural progression
was being coming obsessed with the
ability to be able to convey your vision
as a director and I have now been trying
to I think my first real throw into it
was being you know becoming a proper
producer on the movies that I'm making
and having a big hand in the creation of
it and now my brother Trevor and I are
actually going to co-direct together but
we're gonna start small we're gonna
start with short films so what's this
short film do you already have something
I do have something and it's it's a neo
noir thriller actually I love genre
shocker being that I've only made a
hundred
genre I'm just gonna do a follow up in
the net won't pressure you but who wrote
it and when are you making it uh so well
I tried to get it made last year but my
time keeps escaping me and I don't want
to rush it I want to be able to give the
amount of time that I need for the
post-production predominantly because
there's a quite a bit that I need to do
but my brother Colin actually wrote it
and this is not a nepotism in its finest
right he brought it to me to hear my
opinion on it and I was like this is
absolutely brilliant it it to give a
little bit of tippet the greatest
darkness is your own ego and if you
allow your own ego through the door
it'll be the thing that consumes you and
kills you in the end
I completely understand that yeah um I
definitely want to ask you these are a
few other random questions that promise
they're harmless
go ahead what TV show would you love to
guest star on um the crown loves you so
at the crown uh do you have a favorite
sci-fi or fantasy film probably like the
classic alien vs. predator like it's
just one of those that gets to me that I
watch the young kid and I was like this
is so good right like Sigourney and like
the proper you know I mean completely um
do you have a favorite superhero movie
one that you've not been in kick-ass
right um hmm probably Batman Begins do
you have what films scared you as a kid
7 or silence the limbs okay
naturally of course and I'm sure you saw
them when you were like 7 I was I was 7
which is so inappropriate that's exactly
the age though I don't want to say
anything but I'll blame your brother or
brothers brothers exactly is there
anything that you collect um I collected
snow globes for years and I stopped
doing that but now I I like to steal
articles of things from set which is a
follow-up question what movie and TV
show props do you have um I have a Willy
Wonka bar from filming kick-ass at
Elstree Studios where they did Willy
Wonka so I have the like original Willy
Wonka chocolate bar that I stole from
the prop room there you see borrow wool
and then on Hugo we that incredible the
incredible sets we had on Hugo they were
perfectly done and I I stole one of the
the books which was a book from I think
they like got the books from a museum I
stole it from oh my god take it and I
still have it on my table I will never
invite you to anything you know anyway
moving um was just thinking about you
borrowing stuff Oh what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once sharp objects I found it really
interesting to watch Amy's performance
over and over it's probably most recent
one I watched it three times
sure I'm not a stalker I'm not Greta you
I promise
Amy um do you never you've been working
the entertainment industry for really
long
but do you remember what it was as a
young kid that said I want to do this I
think what really hit me is when I
always loved doing it I always loved
evoking emotion within myself and
jumping into these characters I think in
wearing their skin for a little bit but
I think what really hit me is when I was
I think seven years old or eight years
old maybe even nine years old and I
watch Breakfast at Tiffany's and I
remember laughing and then
simultaneously starting to cry and I
remember that emotion I felt in the
change of emotion I felt and how it it
taught me something about myself that I
could laugh and then cry in that way and
I remember that I wanted to evoke that
emotion other people and I wanted to be
able to be a catalyst for people to find
a deeper part of themselves open up
you